so what I like about this moment here is
Keanu stabs him in the neck straight up
into the brain and just watches him die
I mean it's brutal
but that's why we love it hi GQ this is
Scott Adkins I am a martial arts actor
and today I'll be breaking down fights
from the John Wick franchise
[Music]
okay to start with we have John Wick one
and it's the home invasion scene
Keanu Reeves he's so well trained for
this part that's really what makes the
difference that's what separates him as
an action star from many others the
chats to halski David Leach 8711 stunt
team they trained Keanu so well with the
Jujitsu and the Judo and the gun work of
course that's what part of what makes it
special for me
the films are quite over the top but the
martial arts is very realistic and
reality based you're seeing Real
Techniques supplied and real gun
scenarios
oh
that looks like a tomonegie as he's
thrown the guy through the window that's
a judo move and again it's got this
Scrappy vibe to it real martial arts
techniques
he's using a lot of karate chops
this is the best part for me I mean
showing it all in one long take Keanu
Reeves is doing legitimate martial arts
a nice Oso tagari take down there and
it's the battle over the knife you know
working with the stunt guys it's more in
line with dancing than it is with real
fighting you are cooperating together
it's a violent dance where you've got to
work together to make it look like
you're trying to take each other's heads
off but actually it's a partnership John
Wick chapter 2 Subway fight scene with
common let's have a look
love that bit just knees the knife in
keanu's reaction is great
it's hot class assassins coming out of
each other in it's uh Close Quarters
combat scene done in a very realistic
way it looks like a drop scene I get
cross arm dropsy and Aggie there when he
throws him over
he's probably landing on a pad of course
and why not this Frame down it's a low
angle low angle to accentuate the
movement so that the body is coming
towards the camera to make it look even
more impressive I mean what you want to
try and do is fill the frame with
beautiful action as much as you can I
hate it when you just see two people
stacked together like that because they
want to make a punch work and the punch
comes through here and it goes all the
way out the other side if you open it up
in the frame like that fill the frame
with the action he's going to throw him
over the top category so get a nice low
angle get the legs to come close to the
camera it just makes it look much better
yeah
what makes it so good is that like
common for instance I don't know how
much martial arts training he had
previously but I do know that if you're
going to make a John Wick movie you're
gonna do six six months of training for
this and that's non-negotiable and it
shows that way you can have those shots
where you see the two performers in the
frame working with each other you don't
have to shake the camera to hide the
misgivings of the performers you can
just put it back and show them and let
them do their thing so well done comma
John Wick chapter two again
the pencil kill scene
[Music]
do we have Heidi Money Maker amazing
stuntwoman
nice kick by Heidi there oh she got him
and he takes her out with a curry Ashi
barrier I believe throws her down hard
[Music]
when you get thrown through a tempered
glass window you're probably gonna get
cut it will be a superficial cut
hopefully they'll put two charges at
least just before you hit the window
they'll blow the charge but if one of
the charges doesn't blow then at least
you got a backup of a second one they'll
blow it just before you hit it and
you're going to go through now there
have been instances where you've either
hit before it's blown or it hasn't blown
and you've hit gone through the window
but then you've lost your momentum and
then all that glass is going to come
down it's going to land on you it
actually happened to me in a Jackie Chan
film The Medallion I punch a window they
shattered it and all the glass came down
and the glass landed on my hand and cut
it open this is my particular favorite
fight from John Wick chapter three
Parabellum
The Knife Fight
now I was amazed when I found out the
glass is not real every time they're
smashing the glass it's all CG and I
couldn't believe that this is such an
inventive fight scene and I like John
Wick 3. well I like German for the most
but John week three I like the most to
this point because they're adding more
martial arts now it's a mixture of
different martial arts with Aikido and
Jiu Jitsu and Judo and karate
John Wick does a lot of karate strikes
which I really appreciate because I
haven't seen those since Roger Moore was
James Bond and it just suits the
character so well I love that bit there
if you just rewind that bit
when he swings the arm around and breaks
the arm on the other shoulder
I love that okay the stable fight
get control of the weapon that's the
most important thing
great martial arts it's Scrappy some
sort of a Ponce and Aggie there and
again
you can't have too much of a good thing
with horses kicking people in the face
sending for a ride attach him to the
horse and this bit here mounting the
horse like that I mean that's not easy
the amount of training that he does just
for that simple small throw away shot
they must have trained for ages to get
that move down incredible
John Wick chapter three Parabellum again
this time the fight with
my favorite Mark de cuscus
[Music]
is such an amazing martial artist such a
great guy he plays a brilliant part in
this film that is a turn and cook or
round kick I would call it followed by a
spinning back kick
again John Wick with the karate Chomps I
love that I love the fact that he does
karate chops and again Chad is just so
inventive the way he's using the windows
and the reflections the shadows and
there's no
other place that a fight scene can exist
at this level than in a movie because so
many techniques of filmmaking come into
play right you've got the shots the
angles You've Got the Music you've got
the sound effects every sort of
filmmaking technique that you can think
of is needed in order to create a fight
sequence so for me filming a fight
sequence it is pure Cinema okay the
movie we've all been waiting for John
Wick chapter four
let's meet killer all right here I come
dispose it
I'm in a fat suit okay so you've got to
understand I've been bugging the
director since John Wick wanted to put
me in the movies eventually gives me a
call he says right we're doing John Wick
4 Scott I've got I think I've got a role
for you do you want to do it I'm like my
course I do mate come on what's the role
he says it's probably not what you think
but it was important to us to actually
sell the weight we didn't want to be
doing a load of light jump in the
spinning kicks and all the rest of it so
we keep the techniques simple and
grounded and we decided that this guy
would probably fight like a kickboxer
he's got a bit of a Mike Tyson style
bobbin and weaving and throwing hard
punches heavy kicks let's see I come
straight out of the gates here with a
step through side kick and this was with
John Wick's stunt double Vincent bullion
the first shot of that we did I actually
clotheslined him and his legs came down
and hit me on the back of the head and I
was a bit bit like whoa I didn't expect
that so we needed to do it again I just
said to Vincent I'm just going to smack
you hard with this mate because I knew
the movement the weight of him needs to
go back anyway to do the Gainer neither
said to him I'm just going to smack you
with this mate and he's like yeah good
but that's what it's all about do it
once hard and then you don't have to do
it a bunch of times but what's funny is
we didn't actually rehearse this I
didn't rehearse anything with Keanu but
he's at a level now where he's so well
trained that we could just come up with
all of this on the spot and he's able to
just do it
this was very difficult actually because
it's a wall of water coming down right
into my face Keanu Reeves is behind that
wall of water so I'm seeing the punches
come through the the wall of water at
the last minute and I've got all the
water going into my eyes so I can't
really see anyway and I'm having to
react to the punch at just the right
moment it wasn't easy it looks really
cool but at the end of the day you're in
a fat suit you're soaking wet
and you've got Keanu Reeves punching you
in the face
here we have a clip from John Wick
chapter four my character killer talking
to the main actors let's go you want to
kill him
I want to kill him
what about you Mr Vic
I'm going to kill you so the accent was
the first thing that I came up with
listening to a lot of German accents
authentic German accents but it was this
guy Ronald Lacy from the Raiders of the
Lost Ark the Gestapo guy his voice if I
took it down a few octaves but he was
like uh yes for our line oh what shall
we talk about and we wanted this whole
thing with my character where he's
asthmatic as well and the laugh would
bring on the cough so I would say using
his voice and to find this to call it
tonight
laugh a little bit
laughs
I thought we'd play a game
one hand I was very happy with the card
trick here I was working on my card
skills all the time in the run-up to
this movie every take I was able to
flick the card and not even look at the
card I was looking straight at Reeves
and I catch it without even looking at
the card I was very impressed with
myself when I did that
yes didn't even look at the card that
skill
that's martial arts right there thanks
GQ for watching with me I hope you
enjoyed I'll see you again soon